and it's amazing because Society expects
it of you but so do women if you had a
man be honest you had a man and you went
to your man and said oh I've got this
problem it's I can't fix this it's
broken the car Tire's broken and he went
I don't know you would dry up like you'd
be like well [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
boy are you that's the truth you could
see her and goal we call a mechanic no
you wouldn't dude look at your man go
what do you mean you can't fix it
yeah and this is what she's saying about
your man will get up and go and you know
what's beautiful about mastodoni a bunch
of times the man will go up and he
doesn't have a clue how to fix himself
but he'll go don't worry baby okay and
he'll stand up with no money and no clue
and he'll go out there and [ __ ] try
and find a way because there's a man you
need to be useful it is so difficult to
be a man you have no idea the amount of
pressure that we're under from society
and from the women we even want to
associate with on a whole is difficult
you have to keep all these things in
mind it's hard